too early for the dairy to hit you
that's what you think
[Music]
we're at Disneyland okay we're gonna try
the life of their holiday treat
[Music]
this is a Mickey sheep holiday laser
cookie it's
with strawberry jelly and
a holiday staple here
holiday churro and it's covered with
chocolate and little government
so it basically tastes like a peppermint
hot chocolate
these are Jerome ice
in on gelato
in the break personal
really hot row
so much I've had an annual pass almost
every year of my life so yes I am an AP
that's an annual pass holder VIP only
I'm just here for the food my full name
is actually John in a mini Bell
me all after Disney characters
I'm still here for the food
[Music]
the inside is like Oreo and cookies
and it's just a perfect textured macaron
shell though mac and cheese with
tomatoes
this little romance
[Music]
this is Marisa this is like the size of
my face
[Music]
the holding
which is basically pizza covered and
Thanksgiving leftovers
so there's mashed potatoes there's
there's
there's vegetables
a little bit of gravy and
[Applause]
potato peelers actually
[Applause]
[Music]
almost like
chicken noodle soup but with a lot of
spice a lot of vegetables
oh yeah
we're done trying so many wonderful
delicious holiday treats at Disneyland
we ate a fudge
ready for a nap what do you guys think
was your favorite
I really liked the donut ad schmoozing
and I really like to see throughout my
today I think my favorite was definitely
Mickey shapes at Windsor goofy they're
all really good I'm not really coming
back for more
a really good day and we were ready to
go to sleep
[Music]
wedding
it's holiday season
[Music]
[Music]